always date loners that have no friends
more off the story yeah no no no date
girls that have friends so that they
have their own friends you take loers
they become your friends friends you're
right do that you think this is weird
let's say my son gets a phone and I
start following all his
homie what
[Music]
the all right this one's not very
complicated at all it's a very simple
idea uh we got an Australian woman who
in interview she revealed that in a
single year she had sex with 300 guys
whoa we're clapping I think I saw this
on Twitter that's almost a dude for
every day almost yeah but it's also not
only dudes I think she I think she
dabbles in in both sides you think she's
like do you think some days she'll be
like three and then some days she'll
take a yeah break yeah she said her her
Max one day is five wa wow but she said
that it feels very empowering yeah it
was empowering right I saw this on
Twitter what do you think about that
that's cool I mean what whatever you
want to do I don't if that empowers your
[__] do more of it if you got to get
your nuts off go get your nuts off I
don't understand what's empowering about
it yeah I don't understand empowering
part just let 300 men destroy you as
long as you're saving Sunday for the
Lord I don't
care do what you want to do I'm just mad
I wasn't one of
them 300 that's disgusting I'm not going
to lie the initial response from me was
like bro that's so crazy you're working
hard at that what's an what's an
appropriate to you guys personally I
don't know what's an appropriate yearly
count but if I was if I was single and
she was like want some [__] I'd
probably be like y
y very honest but what if it was a guy
friend and he wait wait what does she
look like is she hot yeah is she banging
oh yeah let's pull her up I mean to be
honest if you're to pull 300 dudes a
year you can't be you you got I feel
like I can pull 300 dudes a year like
that's not hard I got those
easy she felt empowered because she was
like oh I oh she's fine she's bad as
[__] you know what she's beautiful she
could [__] a thousand I'll forget V
loves her well that's probably what's
empowering the fact that she can pull
300 that means she's not ugly but to be
honest you could be ugly and probably
pull 300 that's true too that's true but
I have a question W talk if she said
like hey like she slit on you and she
wanted to [__] then would you say yes
knowing that she is Fu well I'm celibate
so no okay if you oh you SEL it yeah but
that means no sex yeah what's your rules
when when are you going to so
realistically it was it's like I I've
tried to I'm trying to not have
meaningless hookups anymore so did you
go too far or something did you have 300
in one year I was a [__] yeah okay bet
you were do it it does get what's the
word it just feels like desensitizing no
yeah it it starts like destroy your
ability to emotionally connect and I
want like a wife and kids and [__] so
like so I was like oh I'm like really
working backwards here at my goals so
then I was like and it and it felt like
almost like well I should be able to do
this not every guy can get laid so it's
like I should take advantage of it yeah
it was almost like I should be taking
advantage better eat those peaches wow
wait I have a question for you guys
because you guys had internet Fame for a
long time did that help you a lot in
getting girls so I [__] up cuz I
already had a chick
before JK so he regrets it so there is
many lonely nights where me and Joe do
like a show uhhuh and then Joel's like
can I get the main bedroom I'm like of
course
sire go ahead sire dad and I'll sleep on
the pull out couch you know are sleeping
at the edge of the bed I I'll sit on the
pull out couch and I'll I'll have a
picture of my girlfriend and go I'm not
a
loser you weren't a loser though no you
weren't no that's what everyone I mean
not everyone but most life I wish I
lived it want someone that loves some I
would say it was more so my age
were okay like e you there's still girls
right no matter what when you when you
have a audience that like you but I
think the older I got the hotter and I
guess the quality of women are different
that's what I'm noticing CU when you're
when you're famous in your 20s right the
girls that maybe look up to you are like
what high school and college the same
age right so you're not with like you're
not meeting interesting women that are
not only hot but like accomplished
and the old you get you have M and then
they have M and then it's just a
different exciting world I think and
then um yeah I don't know I I feel like
the age was probably a bigger Factor
than the fame because I probably was
more famous in my early 20s than my late
thir my my but I think it's all it's
like a it's not really clout but it's
like you're a guy doing something that
and and it's like especially you're
doing something that's rare to to see
that's what I feel like it's less like
it's less like girls that are fans that
like I was hooking up with and more like
girls that are like oh this this is a
guy that's like doing well for himself
like has all this going on like you know
what I'm saying like people like all of
those factors are like attractive I
think across the board yeah you're a
higher value yeah yeah yeah oh you know
what the biggest wingman was was my
ex-girlfriend so after we publicly broke
up the floodgates just freaking open and
also Steve Steve he's not here today but
he he's he's like the best wingman in
the world just hook me up with every
single person he thinks wants to I don't
know um you know wants to play Bingo
he's always trying to hook me up and
then so but I think bingo bingo
bingo I I don't know I correct me if I'm
wrong cuz you're the only female here
but I feel like when women see a guy
interact in a relationship they see them
differently than being a single guy on
camera all the time so then after the
relationship I think I have way more DMS
than before the relationship before the
relationship you had less DMs I had DMS
but after the relationship I had way
more than I did in my really ear like
mid to late it's the thing we were
saying about like the uh the
pre-selection Like Girls when they see a
guy especially if it's an attractive
woman if if they see a guy with a baddie
even if they didn't think he was
attractive before they're going to be
like it's like a cosign you know what
I'm saying like what does she see in him
like he must have something that like
that I'm missing yeah it's a validator
exactly I thought that was pretty
interesting cuz I think guys are the
opposite they're like oh you're oh man
you're supposed to save yourself from me
but then you're with that guy and then
it was all over the Internet yeah if if
I see if I'm following a girl that it
was like a follow out of like oh I think
you're cute and then she posts a
boyfriend I unfollow her immed
absolutely cuz like my only purpose was
to like probably like and then you start
following the boyfriend and then you say
kill yourself kill yourself the only
version of that I get now is [__]
kids at the park I'm I'm with my I'm
with my I'm with my son at the park and
I think I'm like probably one of the
more physical dads so I'm playing with
them we go crazy and then I think all
the other kids are like Dad Dad is down
to go on the jungle gym so now there's
[__] eight other kids that are coming
I'm like get the [__] out of wait so the
kid you not not the single moms it's the
kids that are come not the single the
other [__] kids he's a fun hang sure
single moms are Whispering about you
though when they see you on the they're
like dude he's [__] his ass eating up
those short stand up and show your ass
dude show your ass got short shorts on
all the time they're probably like
looking not is that short shorts or is
that long underwear
both do you guys view social media
differently now than before like you
know how I don't know you know how I'm
very possessive when it comes to like
guys and social media like do you let
are you okay with your girl like adding
another man hell no dude I don't even
know who I don't even know who she's
adding I don't know who she's adding or
following or liking I don't give a [__]
I don't got time and I tell her I tell
her this is a patrion I'm the weird one
you're the weird one you know what she
wouldn't let her man uh follow her
friends back good that's right I like to
keep everyone so like if your dude met
your friends through you like that like
let's say she has a boyfriend her her if
her best friend if they meet and they've
hung out 10 times she's like y'all
cannot follow each other has anything
ever happened in the past with one your
friends interesting no no but then it's
her best friend did you ever have a
friend in your past that like [__]
your boyfriend well not not not [__]
but was very shady around them and then
the thing is I consider her my best
friend but you're not friends with her
no more no not anymore but no I trust my
friends that's okay that's merited
trauma yeah yeah so the thing is like I
trust my friends but because of that
trauma I know that I shouldn't put it on
them but I'm just like damn like they
don't they don't need to be talking to
each other they know they don't like my
friend doesn't have to what if you guys
break up and he has to [__]
her yeah you're not being considerate no
like you know like let's just say my
friend is having a barbecue right and
she doesn't have to like go out of a way
to like be like hey like Mike you know
like Mike is my boyfriend right in this
case like hey Mike I'm having a barbecue
come through you know like it's just
like tell me like Esther I'm having a
barbecue invite what if you're busy busy
day no I'm not I'm not that busy I'll
she not I'm not that busy I'll read it
huh I have a question for you so and why
do you want Mike so bad huh why do you
want him at the barbecue it's not even
that fun okay so I I understand I
understand I'm actually encouraging of
cheating you know why I want to see them
quick I want to see I want to see I
don't I'm not going to I'm not going to
fight it I want I'm a put them in
situations I'mma buy them a [__] Rose
and just leave it there and be like I
think somebody left that for you guys
what do you think I want them to do you
want to see what they would do if yeah
okay so in your case like you're you're
you're holding it back but if if they
already a cheater girl they're going to
[__] do that you're right you're very
you got to find out I actually feel like
it's better to have less boundaries in
that case yeah you want the colors to
show up earlier on yeah I mean it's true
like on the front face show them that
you trust on the back end just trust
everything and set up traps you know
what you're right because the thing is
the best relationship whoever whoever
wants to cheat eventually they're going
to cheat no matter what you do no matter
how crazy you act they're going to cheat
it's like to show you you know the show
you that girl was crazy love was crazy
but he still that was so hot she was so
hot you is my wife you know what's a
sick ass trap like those Knives have
been in Joe's nose and y'all just been
like playing with him the whole time
that's TI I deep throwed it on the other
the handle side very impressive yeah
this is a long one wait are you being
for real that you you don't want Tiff
following God n joking jokingly not he's
being for real I feel like that was real
we be talking [__] though I feel like
he's the most machismo guy in here that
doesn't so like let's say you did a
Jiu-Jitsu match and then after the match
he followed the opponent that beat
you I know that's bad that beat you was
crazy guess what guess that's that's
when I just drop everything dude and I
just dedicate my whole life I like that
guy's tasting GES like oh and she knows
I'm insecure about my ghe tastes you
know I me she knows I'm insecure about
that and you ask her why did you follow
him and she goes he has nice shoes and I
was like she's like he w I was like yeah
he's Salvadoran have you guys ever been
cheated on any of you yeah dude cuz I
encouraged it oh man he set the Trap and
she fell for the TR he sent the jiggalo
after her and then and then she
gaslights him what you you wanted me to
I do think though just women are better
at it because we're [__] stupid and
if they do it they do it right but then
also I think because I've been cheated
on very early on it was my first
girlfriend she lost her virginity to the
dude so I didn't even get to [__] her
yet yeah that was a blow and I was only
like 13 14 years old so I was like [__]
bro like that was that took me 2 years
to get over but then that's how I think
I kind of reworked it in my mind like
it's a good thing because what if this
person I was high school sweethearts
with till ever we got married we had
kids and she's been a hoe that would
have been even more devastating but
thank God I got rid of that at 14 yeah
she did what she would rather do you got
over with it and then my mind became
more like if it happens it happens it's
just [__] you know let them let them
do it uh and then at least I get to see
it early on that is true yeah you're
right and sometimes it's just people
like [__] happens the older you get to I
feel like you're just more forgiven
about [__] like that too it's just
that's true it's not it doesn't mean
everything it's just people get horny
yeah you got let Hoes Be ho but I feel
like girls are not cheating just cuz
they're horny usually I feel like it's
it's always almost like more yeah well
it's like a lack of something else and
then it's like it's because like they're
seeing something in this guy that you
were not you know what I'm saying it's
almost like yeah there's something else
going on that I don't understand as a
caveman
male also though like on your possessive
nature I don't think you got to worry
too much about like your guy following I
think it's like on him to worry about
that you know what I mean like his
decisions should reflect like how you
should feel about it versus you making
decisions for him yeah no I I don't want
to like for example like uh Like Us in
Us in like our crew we got like hella
dudes in our in our dance crew right and
I think all the fellas don't follow the
homies girl unless they get
married yeah yeah no no no I I I I know
why they do that you know but like
that's just like a unspoken rule because
it's like one you end up following a
homies girl cuz you think that they're
going to be together and then they break
up and then that shit's all awkward
anyway that's true that's true the
second you do that twice you're like I'm
[__] over I'm never following another
girl until like you marry them and
you're like this is your for life you
know what I'm saying exactly okay so
would you guys be okay if you had a if
you had a girlfriend and you guys broke
up but you guys have she's following all
of your homies and would you be upset if
your homies didn't unfollow her it was
it was a really bad breakup oh if she
like wronged me then yeah I'd expect
them to unfollow her but also I don't
really care that but who talk but who
talk she's she's friends with all of
your friends no already dialed in yeah
no they're not they're not close because
those are my friends I'm taking them the
divorce they with me I don't like mixing
friends either so yeah I think it's hard
the difference is like did she wrong you
or was it just like a bad breakup
because like you guys didn't work out
well that's why Always date loners that
have no friends more of the story yeah
no date girls that have friends so that
they have their own friends you date
loers they become your friends friends
you're right do that about immediate
switch you think this is weird let's say
my son gets a phone and I start
following all his homies what the [__]
you think that's weird or that's weird
that's very weird I that being too
possessive cuz he's the most popular guy
at the park that's why Bart's [__]
getting validation from his [__]
son's friends no you're right I need I'm
the cool
dad just kidding news careful boys is a
brand just kidding news is the man of
smart people the people of just kidding
news careful boys they are very smart
just kiding news the number one foot in
the
[Music]
world